what's popping quados it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
let's go on ahead and break down episode
7 of Rick and Morty season 7 shall we so
sit back relax and open your mind
because we about to get into it the
episode starts with Summer doing a bunch
of chores that Rick has neglected to do
around his various subbasements
including cleaning up the mess that Rick
and Morty left behind all the way back
during Morty's mindblowers in season 3
episode 8 a room that Rick would return
back to later on in the episode when
looks for summer around the house and
when he does we can see the names of
some of Rick's vials of memories
including micro TI LOL virginity
Stanford te- balls and pocket poo which
sounds like something I definitely want
to forget but anyways when summer gets
fed up with doing chores she forces her
Grandpa to pay up by designing her an
attribute slider in the style of a pit
boy from The Fallout video game series a
series full of attribute sliders so that
Gamers can make the character of their
choosing but anyways after summer slaps
on her attribute slider that allows her
to alter her levels of strength Charisma
dexterity and intelligence summer
sacrifices a good bit of her
intelligence in exchange for the
strength to lift her Grandpa up in the
air like we see her do in the new theme
intro for season 7 Morty then barges in
and complains that he doesn't have an
attribute slider of his own to which
summer calls him a bottom feeder who
begs for scraps which is something that
Rick later reveals that he agrees with
when he calls Morty a dog in comparison
to Summer who he treats like an equal
because Summer reminds him of his dead
wife Diane which could actually explain
why Rick chooses to not adventure with
summer as much as he does with Morty I
mean it has been established in the past
that Rick primarily chooses to hang out
with Morty the most because the Morty
waves that Morty produces helps Shield
Rick from undesired detection but I
think that Rick also prefers Morty over
summer because he might not want to risk
losing summer if one of those Adventures
goes aai I mean yeah he can always go to
to another universe and get a new summer
but it wouldn't be this summer from his
version of the Smith family so there
could be a degree of protectiveness that
Rick has for summer even though he knows
damn well that summer can take care of
her own damn self that girl's a little
badass man but hey grandpas will always
worry over their granddaughters but
anyways when we get to the big teenage
frisbee golf party we can see that the
party has a May the course Be With You
poster and Banner in a reference to May
the force be with you from Star Wars a
couple of summers's friends from past
episode show up at the big party
including Trisha Lang who first appeared
in season 3 episode 5's the worldly
durly conspiracy as Summer's competition
for Summer's ex-boyfriend Ethan Bradley
Kay who is one of the star players of
the Harry herpson herpson football team
as well as Nancy a friend that we
learned that sum are bullied and treated
like all the way back in season 1
episode 11's risky business but they
managed to work things out and now
they're friends again Morty and summer
then start fighting over the attribute
slider leading to Morty maxing out
Summer's intelligence to make her weak
enough to overpower her for the slider
choosing to make himself super strong
but unfortunately this hul out Morty
doesn't know that his dumbass just
accidentally gave summer the genius
powers and forehead of the leader from
Marvel Comics using her Mastery over
math trajectories and probabilities to
make the perfect fra throw that would
trip and humiliate her little brother
the two then fight some more before
inevitably having their spines
genetically braided together after they
fall into the pool with the attribute
slider turning that party pool into a
literal genan pool which I thought was
hilarious summer then emerges from the
pool with Morty as her new stomach quat
which is of course a reference to the
tiny psychic stomach mutant of the same
name from 1990s Total Recall starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger free your mind is
the only thing that Morty says in this
episode because it's a famous quote from
quad in Total Recall when he's trying to
get Schwarzenegger's character to open
his mind so that quad could tap into his
memories this is actually the second
quad reference of the Season as Rick
Prime had a quad of his own while
fighting evil Morty in episode 5 summer
then interrupts Rick's interdimensional
cable viewing of cake or fake which is a
show parody of the internet memes where
people make cakes into realistic objects
that don't look like cakes at all
leading Rick to tell summer to do more
chores for him in exchange for his help
while summer takes a break from feeding
Rick's alien plants in his little
workshop of Horrors summer Scrolls
through Instagram stories from the frol
party before having the Instagram
algorithm convince her to head to the
Mind opener Club on another planet an
open your mind poster can be seen on the
outside of the club before summer heads
inside with the first person that summer
actually runs into being the same woman
that summer would of course end up
dating by the end of the episode
confirming summer to be just as bisexual
as her mother is which is super dope but
anyways right before this woman
compliments summer in the club she says
oh My Glob which is also a popular
saying in the cartoon series Adventure
Time but is likely just being used as a
reference to the Globs of Flesh that all
the quados in the club have hanging off
of their stomachs then as summer and
Morty order drinks at the bar you could
actually see quiet watching Summer from
afar at his table like the quad
trafficking creep that he is before he
actually approaches her quiet then
introduces summer to Kenneth who has
very much given himself a very Jesus
Christ type of look likely very
intentionally because he himself is a
leader of a cult I mean if Jared let can
do it Kenneth can too and notice that
Kenneth yells I love being a quad in the
same Cadence as the Ninja Turtles yell I
love being a turtle which I thought was
kind of fun but what isn't Fun is summer
being betrayed by quiet in a similar
vein to how Brian Mills daughter Kim is
kidnapped in the 2008 Taken movie but
instead of Summer being taken it was her
quad Morty with Summer being left to a
fiery fate were it not for summer being
the badass that she is using her
special set of skills summer gets her
own damn Ginger ass self out of her own
situation With a Little Help from Rick's
cybernetic ponytail that he mentions
earlier in the episode basically giving
her the powers of Medusa from the
Inhumans Beth later notices some are
missing and sends Rick to go find her as
Rick is looking for Beth we can see a
green and yellow Mandalorian helmet
inside of this container here alongside
Muir and what looks like the visor of
Cyclops from the X-Men then Rick goes on
a tear throughout space punching random
aliens like Brian Mills and taken before
eventually running into summer who
reveals to Rick that Morty was brought
to a taken house after summer learns to
open her mind to Morty the psychic place
that summer goes to while she connects
to Morty looks a lot like 11 psychic
place from stranger things shout out to
our editor Matt for that one Morty is
even being auctioned off in a similar
fashion to how Kim was in Taken Rick and
summer then go after Morty at the taken
house which then leads Rick to jumping
out of a window with Summer only for his
cybernetic butt implants to inflate and
cushion their fall like I truly love
just how much of an Inspector Gadget
parody Rick has made himself because
this man's body has an impossible amount
of Technology inside including a
freaking shoulder laser apparently just
in case anyone with tongs gets too close
while Rick is sleeping but anyways after
Rick reveals that he views summer as an
extension of her grandmother the gang
confronts Kenneth who reveals that he is
actually several layers deep within
multiple quados which is kind of weird
then Morty bust through the roof and
bites the evil quad's ear off just like
Mike Tyson did at the MGM Grand Arena in
Las Vegas on June 28th 1997 then after
the three dispose of the Kenneth quad in
the sea and steal his walking device
quad Morty finally gets the frol
acceptance that he always wanted at the
end of the episode as he scores a
winning point for the Harry Herson
Herson frol team before accidentally
firing the missiles and destroying
everything and finally the post-credit
scene features a parody of the evil
massed millionaires from squid game in
particular the evil man in The Mask who
bet on the squid game player 69 with all
the masked man in Rick and Morty all
making 69 jokes and one of those men
even has their legs up on an animal
themed servant much like we see in Squid
game itself but anyways that is it for
this breakdown of episode 7 of Rick and
Morty season 7 again I want to give a
special shout out to our editor Matt who
helped me a lot with some of the Easter
eggs in this episode that man is amazing
go follow him @ superhero Nexus on
Twitter and you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter and Instagram
if you guys want to see me post some
weird but most importantly follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube because
you guys don't want to miss anything
that we upload at any point in time
because we got stuff for you pretty much
constantly but again thank you guys so
much for watching I'm very thankful for
you guys I hope you guys have an amazing
Thanksgiving if you guys celebrate and
I'll see you guys later bye